[Musique]
ne me quitte pas il faut oublier tout
peut s'oublier
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé quand
je suis né le médecin chantait et puis
il s'est arrêté et il a dit hey hey il y
à un deuxième bébé
il y en a un autre sens échographie et
avec nos coeur qui battait simultanément
c'était une véritable surprise dernier
d'une fratrie de cinq enfants
on nous appelait toujours les jumeaux
mais j'ai vite appris que pour trouver
la juste place
il allait falloir me singularise et
parce que même si nous étions proches et
très liés l'un à l'autre
nous avons chacun notre adn
puisque nous sommes des êtres unique et
singulier quelques dizaines d'années
plus tard à l'ère du numérique
nous sommes tous virtuellement et
potentiellement reliés les uns aux
autres nous faisons partie d'un tout et
les traces que nous laissons sur
internet représente notre identité
numérique
cette année le 21 juillet nous allons
fêter les premiers les 50 ans du premier
pas de l'homme sur la lune
savez vous quelle est la différence
entre les traces de porc de neil
armstrong sur le sol lunaire lors de ses
explorations en 1969 et celle que nous
laissons aujourd'hui en 2019 sur
internet
elles sont toujours là et elles le
seront pendant longtemps encore ces
traces elles sont volontaires ou
involontaires alors volontaire c'est
quand vous effectuez par exemple un
achat sur un site de e-commerce ou quand
vous exprimer une opinion ou un avis ou
même une émotion sur le site d'une
grande marque volontaires 70
pratiquement
ce avait créé un profil sur un réseau
social personnel et éventuellement
professionnel ça à renforcer votre
identité une numérique involontaire
c'est par exemple quand vous découvrez
une photo de vous en faites vous avez
été identifié par une amie du lycée qui
tout d'un coup a eu envie de retrouver
ses copains d'avant
bon sauf que cette photo elle est
vraiment pas à votre avantage
pour ma part quand je vais sur un réseau
social professionnel réputé
je suis souvent frustré par là le
décalage qu'il ya entre la richesse
personnelle et professionnelle de ce que
je connais que je côtoie et de ce que je
vois de leur profil qui sont souvent
très peu aligné alors j'ai acquis une
conviction profonde
notre idée n notre identité numérique
devrait être le plus proche possible de
notre adn
et si possible de nos valeurs parce que
cet alignement représente ce qui va nous
singulariser et nous différencier des
autres
la plupart des jeunes ici ont créé des
profils sur les réseaux sociaux
professionnels
aujourd'hui ils sont à l'aise avec
internet ils y vont pour se nourrir
l'information pour se forger une opinion
pour partager des idées avec des
personnes avec lesquelles ils sont en
concordance et ils y vont s'y pour
développer leur employabilité et trouver
leur premier job mais qu'en est il des
seniors et notamment de ce qu'ils
doivent ou qui veulent trouver leur
dernier job
alors on va faire un petit intermède je
vais proposer à tous les seniors de la
salle ceux qui osent de se mettre debout
et de le rester
merci à ceux qui osent oui je suis pas
tout seul maintenant j'ai proposé à tous
ceux qui ont plus de 45 ans resté debout
de rejoindre ceux qui sont se sont levés
et de rester debout également alors eh
bien vous savez quoi nous tous de vous
et oui nous sommes tous des seniors vous
pouvez vous rasseoir
merci 45 ans je vous l'annonçais pour
ceux qui ne le savent pas c'est l'âge de
la séniorité professionnel s'est
d'ailleurs inscrit dans la loi de
formation 2019 pour avoir la liberté de
choisir notre vie professionnelle pour
gagner en employabilité et en capacité
d'adaptation à des nouveaux métiers
alors en france pour autant on considère
les seniors un peu comme vous savez nos
vieux meubles de famille on les respecte
on a souvent de l'infection et puis en
plus ils ont été bien amortie pour
autant quand il y à un nouvel
environnement
on sent lâche finalement ils ont fait
leur temps et alors on s'en débarrasse
c'est un peu ce que j'ai expérimenté bon
c'est une image lors de mon entretien
professionnel légale pour les plus de 50
ans j'ai été convoqué et mon manager du
haut de ses 35 ans m'a demandé avec un
air un peu gêné et toi karine qu'as-tu
prévu pour la suite de ta carrière
professionnelle pendant 25 ans dans sept
grandes entreprises de l'informatique
je vais surfer sur l'innovation
technologique les premiers e-mails et
smartphones les solutions mobiles
internet pour mieux connaître les
clients les réseaux sociaux pour mieux
connaître les acheteurs de
au client et tout d'un coup c'était mon
tour je prenais conscience que les
perspectives à être moins ouverte et la
pression pour un départ plus ou moins
volontaires plus forte
je vais à nouveau partager une petite
histoire personnelle
la crise du pétrole 1973 a frappé de
plein fouet tous les chantiers des
travaux publics est mis au chômage des
milliers de personnes dont mon père
directeur de grands travaux à la
cinquantaine il a pendant dix ans subit
des conditions financières et sociales
assez pitoyable mais de nature optimiste
et enthousiaste c'est une famille il
gardait toujours espoir parce qu'il
avait toujours en tête les rêves de
voyages qui le ferait à la retraite à 60
ans l'âge légal à l'époque
sauf qu'il est décédé six mois avant la
retraite
il était hors de question que j'attende
il était hors de question que je prenne
la poussière
j'avais fait le tour de cette grande
entreprise j'avais encore tant de choses
à faire
alors j'ai créé ma petite entreprise et
d'ailleurs il était largement temps que
je transmette ce que j'avais appris
expérimenter les méthodes et les
techniques pour accompagner les
entreprises les dirigeants et leurs
équipes et les individus dans la
transition numérique
c'était le bon moment c'est comme cela
que j'ai formé des managers de
transition tous des seniors de plus de
45 ans à se vendre pour trouver de
nouvelles missions et développer leur
employabilité
je leur disais
vous êtes un cadeau avec ou savoir faire
vous savoir être avec vos capacités vos
compétences avec vos expertises vous
êtes vos expériences et vous êtes un
cadeau le problème c'est que c'est
compliqué de révéler ce cadeau aux
entreprises parce que notre éducation
notre culture ne nous ont pas poussé à
nous valoriser à nous singulariser or
les dirigeants d'entreprises et les
recruteurs sont sur les réseaux sociaux
professionnels
il cherche la perle rare parmi des
milliers de profils
ils y sont il faut y être avec les
réseaux avec ses seniors
nous avons constitué leur identité
numérique en optimisant leurs profils
sur les réseaux sociaux professionnels
et leur présence sur internet avec une
idée n bien travaillé proche de l'adn je
vois bien aujourd'hui que ces seniors
rebondissent ils n'ont plus peur de se
vendre
ils ont confiance il ose même s'exposer
et entrer la relation avec les
dirigeants et les recruteurs avec lequel
ils peuvent être en concordance un
senior cadeau c'est par exemple cet
homme que j'accompagne il a passé toute
sa vie dans le domaine de l'aérien
il a parcouru le monde il a eu des
grandes responsabilités et il a acquis
une expérience multi culturel
exceptionnel mais à 54 ans son dernier
entretien avec une autre société de
recrutement s'est soldée par un désolé
monsieur il n'y a rien dans l'aérien
quel manque d'imagination
l'arrêt est réputé à l'international
comme étant un secteur d'activité
extrêmement exigeant et très réglementé
savez vous que tous les secteurs
d'activité aujourd'hui subissent une
réglementation extrêmement forte et très
exigeante
ce qu'il avait appliqué dans l'aérien
évidemment ils pouvaient l'adapter dans
les autres secteurs d'activité
il a donc optimiser son identité
numérique pour devenir la perle rare que
les dirigeants qui vont à
l'international hors envie de rencontrer
pour ma part
j'assume une présence sur internet assez
gourmande
je revendique un profil sur les réseaux
sociaux professionnels très copieux
c'est que en tant que femmes seniors et
geek et au départ je n'avais aucune
appétence pour la technique
je suis assez fier de témoigner que le
numérique n'aura pas remis de
singulariser et de trouver la juste
place de développer mon employabilité et
de contribuer même modestement à la
communauté alors vous seniors et jeunes
êtes vous prêt à développer votre
employé vite et en créant une identité
numérique au plus proche de votre adn
parce que vous savez vous aussi vous
êtes tous des cadeaux merci pour votre
attention
[Musique]